each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available invisible Q uh thanks
everybody for coming for the sixth and
final series Ender of crypto with senior
cryptographer Josh Beno from Microsoft
research um raise your hand if you've
been to every one of these in person
okay cool awesome good thank you uh and
in the back is that Sandy in the back
yes okay cool um so uh what we're going
to do just to give you a sneak at it is
um uh I'm going to give you guys some um
lockpick sets not like the cheap ones
though like the like the pretty good
ones not over like the area where you
have to sign off the tax thing but as
close as I can get um so it'll be a
little bit of time to order those and
get those shipped to youall in office
mail those to you as well um as well as
probably email you since I have all your
aliases for everybody involved both uh
who's been to any of the sessions we're
going to send out a questionnaire uh I
appreciate your feedback on that so that
uh Josh and his counterparts and people
in security can do more of these more
often as they're relevant so um without
further Ado one more uh Round of
Applause for Mr Josh for all the all the
contribution he's been doing for
cryptography thank you
Josh
thank you Justin and welcome
survivors Sixth and final all right so
um let's let's get going and and get
into sort of um so some of the uh
interesting what you can do with this
just as a reminder if anybody missed the
last session uh we talked about attacks
of various kinds vulnerabilities attacks
especially side Channel attacks but lots
of related um things that could be done
and we talked about uh some of the
practical considerations that often give
rise to these attacks how you can do a
lot of the things that we need to do in
cryptography as efficiently as possible
so this time we're going to move on to
some of the the tools the higher level
things that can be done with crypto um
homomorphic encryption specifically a
few people asked me about uh bilinear
maps and pairing so I'm going to spend
like two minutes just squeezing that in
but I'm not going to do much there just
to give people quick sense secret Shar
zero knowledge and give a few
applications to these the applications
in particular Computing on encrypted
data is becoming a very hot field in a
lot of ways if you think about it for
very obvious reasons if if all your data
is in the cloud and it's
encrypted do you what do you do with it
it's just basically do you use the cloud
as just a big Storehouse and can't do
anything or if you you can actually
encrypt on the data in the cloud you can
do a lot more if you can compute on the
encrypted data in the cloud you can do a
lot more with it the other thing I've
been promising I'm going to talk a
little bit about elections it's a good
motivating example and one near and dear
to my heart so I'll spend a little bit
of time on that so let me start on the
Computing on encrypted data application
um and in particular if you want to work
on on data and do something with the
data in encrypted form um let's remember
what symmetric encryption typically
looks like something of this sort where
you've got sort of an function in here
and you're just taking this data and
making a mess of it right you're you're
trying to remove all structure you're
getting something that looks nothing
like the original or anything else it's
really hard to do anything with data
that's been actively messed up as much
as possible however when we look at what
we do for asymmetric encryption we've
got nice equations right we've got
things like this for RSA where there's a
nice meth mathematical description of
the relationship between the plain text
and the cipher text that we may be able
to work with is that a question so in
particular RSA excuse me is
multiplicative and we we mentioned this
early on a couple months ago I think um
basically if you take an RSA encryption
of one message and an RSA encryption of
a second message and you literally just
multiply these two together multiply
them mod because everything is going on
mod here literally multiply them what
you get if you work it through is a
completely valid encryption of the
product of the two messages now normally
we put in all sorts of padding to
prevent this from happening accidentally
but sometimes we want to be able to do
this we want to be able to take the data
and operate on it and here you know if
we take this as raw RSA take this data
take these two messages in encrypted
form we can multiply them together
together and get a useful bit of
information and uh representation of a
computation this computation in
particular multiplication so RSA isn't
the only example um there are a bunch of
functions like this RSA in particular
has this multiplicative homomorphic
property uh another very common um
function is the elgamal cipher elgamal
is really just you do the Diffy Helman
key exchange and you use that key as a
one-time pad effectively you use that
key and take the key and multiply it by
your message so here's the message here
being multiplied by what would come out
of the Diffy Helman result and the
recipient on the other end can sort of
work this out and remove the key and
just get the message um and if you work
this through there's a pair of values
but if you multiply things appropriately
again you get a multiplicative
homomorphic function um also very
commonly used now there are some others
go wer Mall came up with this function
that looks like this it's designed for
encrypting just a single bit but it has
some nice mathematical properties some
provability um so it was a really
interesting function when it came out
and it has the property that if you
multiply to goas and Mall encryptions
you get an exor of the
bits okay could be useful for something
um years ago too many years literally 25
years ago I generalized this it is 25
years um so here's another function just
a straightforward generalization of that
but what you get is something that's
additively homomorphic if you multiply
two encryptions in this form the trick
is the message is in the exponent here
so with the message in the exponent if
you multiply two things G to the M1 * G
to the M2 becomes G to the M1 plus M2
you get um an additive function um this
uh had some nice properties one not so
nice property was decryption is kind of
cumbersome with this it's possible but
it's kind of cumbersome some
applications that's okay some
applications you want to be able to
decrypt so Pascal P came out about a
dozen years later with a generalization
of this um working mod N squared so you
get some blow up in the cipher Tech size
but has the advantage that decryption is
much more straightforward and easier to
do also additively homomorphic so these
are the most commonly used homomorphic
functions but but you can develop others
um there a whole host to choose from
so we have
these things that we can do we can do
additive we can do multiplicative what
we' really like is something that does
both that was the Holy Grail for decades
if we could
simultaneously add data that's in
encrypted form and multiply data that's
in encrypted form you can provably do
everything you can build out any
function you want from just those two
two operations and it was long thought
that would be great but it's not
possible um nobody was able to prove it
but it was thought this you know this
structurally was just asking too much
until five years ago Craig Gentry um at
IBM found a way to do this now a way to
do this kind of in theory I write it as
wildly
inefficient um if you have another
adjective that you could put there
that's more relative put it there um
wildly in this case is about 25 orders
of magnitude
slower um so um you know 10 to the 25th
power I think you know modern processor
does a couple billion instructions per
second well this is a couple billion
years to do one instruction at this
space yes it's possible in theory really
interesting but not quite practical for
cloud computation but since then there's
been more work done and things have
gotten a lot better um it's still very
inefficient we've shaved off you know a
dozen or so orders of magnitude it's
still about a trillion times slower than
than than not working on encrypted data
but now you can do a cycle every maybe
five minutes or so 10 minutes something
like that we're getting getting there
what's more interesting right now I we
we'd love to get this general form done
people are working there are a lot of
people working on this but what's more
interesting right now is many special
cases really are practical you can't do
you know a full General computation or
of All Sorts but you can do a lot of
specifics um and uh I'll quickly mention
one way of building an interesting
specific and that comes from bilinear
Maps yep what's the status of
homomorphic encryption that's resilient
against
quantm so I'm just curious since you can
can give a one line summary of that oh
well so let me take roll that back a
step and ask what what's the the status
of encryption that's resistant to
Quantum attack
and pretty much all of the um public key
stuff that I talked about is potentially
vulnerable um if you built a good
quantum computer you could
factor that breaks RSA you can compute
discret logs that break stiffy Helman um
some of the um the lattice based things
that I talked about the the um elliptic
um curve based stuff also is is based on
just discret logs some of the um lattice
stuff seems like it may be resistant so
we might want to move that way I talked
about lattice things I don't know a
month and a half ago something like that
those can resist the the ones that I
showed just now all these homomorphic
ones are based on these mathematical
properties that would fall if we were
able to build a a good efficient quantum
computer however the best quantum
computers right now can Factor 15 that's
what we're up to um there's some
promising ideas but there also some
fundamental barriers and it's really not
clear whether or not it's even possible
it might not be a technological limit it
might be a limit of physics we we really
don't know um but there are some some
promising directions that people are
going and there is active work going on
to to talk about postquantum
cryptography what do we need to do to be
ready just in case and there's a lot of
work in that area okay so um let me
spend a couple minutes digressing to
talk about bioline Maps or pairings
people like to talk
sometimes there are people in the room
who know a lot more about this than I do
but I'm going to give you a quick sense
just to give you what we can do and um
the the idea is you have two groups um
we talked about mathematical groups um
when we talked about elliptic curves two
mathematical groups and two elements
with presumably generate and you have a
function um that takes elements of one
group to another group with this
property now
actually excuse me these two things
could actually be separate groups this
could be G1 and G2 but let's not
complicate it let's think of the simpler
case of a pair of things from the same
group going into this other group and it
has this property that if you take G to
the A and G to the B you get the
corresponding H to the ab in the other
group um now this you know little
explanation you Ron Rees showed it to me
about a month ago as a good way to try
to explain it and I think it's it's a
good way to just get a little bit of a
sense of what's going on so first an
important thing to note is that um you
have if you compose with G to the power
one you get H to the a so you can go
from G to the a to H to the a if you
have one of these functions very easily
so if I take a bunch of these objects
any of these I can go to the
corresponding object for in the G group
to the corresponding object in the H
group and the reason I'm listing these
objects is this is the Diffy Helman
problem that we started way out on early
on if you have G and G to the A and G to
the B nobody knows a good way to get to
G to the a from that and but if you have
a or b if you you generated one of these
two then you can get this this was the
Diffy Helman key exchange but nobody
knows how to go from these three to this
one or these three to this one but we
can construct groups with bilinear maps
such that you can go from this pair to
this in this other
group okay I'm not going to go into any
detail about how or why but you can
actually leverage this to do lots of
interesting things one thing in
particular is you can build a
homomorphic encryption function where
you can do as many additions as you want
and you get one multiplication kind of
for free so now here's a slightly more
complicated function that you can do if
you can do most things in addition and
you need to do one multiplication we can
do that and you can go from there small
numbers of multiplications now we can
handle reasonably well fully General
computation not so good but
many special cases we can handle okay so
I'm going to go back and look at one of
the simple ones for a minute and try to
motivate this application that I'm going
to talk more about later so suppose we
have just a simple tively homomorphic
encryption function the kind we had 25
years ago call it eight and I want to
encrypt votes as one encryption of one
is a yes vote encryption of zero is a no
vote all I have to do now is
homomorphically sum the votes and I get
an encryption of the sum so if you think
of this if you want to vote Yes you
encrypt one if you want to vote no you
encrypt zero and we post all these
encryptions anybody can see them and all
I have to do is take them literally just
multiply them together decrypt and you
get the
tally okay that's the basic idea now
there's a lot that's missing here first
of
all who holds the decryption key to do
this right if I hold the decryption key
and can decrypt in the end I can also
decrypt all the intermediate votes and
see how everybody voted probably not
such a good thing um who's actually
doing the encryption right if the voters
encrypt then the voters have to have
some devices that'll do encryption if
you use if they use their own devices
there're these little malware type
issues that might get in the way there's
also coercion kinds of stuff because you
know somebody could
give you their device to use and say you
vote on this device or install something
that captures your vote and there there
are some problems there um how do we
ensure that only zeros and ones are
encrypted right maybe I really one vote
Yes so I'll encrypt a million put that
up there and it gets summed up with all
the zeros and sorry nobody else voted
anything but but zero but I voted a
million we win um so we have a few
issues and I'll I'll get to these later
the encrypted values are either a one or
a zero then there are only two encrypted
values right um not if we use a
randomized concession so yes you're
absolutely right if we use a
deterministic thing like you know
straight RSA is there is there anything
in the randomized encryption that is
compatible with the homomorphic yes
absolutely okay so let that doesn't make
sense to me let me go back a little bit
come on
back so this function I developed for
specifically for use in elections that
was my motivation that was my my
dissertation um so effectively what you
can think of as m is the vote here zero
or one R is a random
value and it turns out if you multiply
two of these things you get um some
other random value to this power e times
G to the sum and because of the way
things are structured the the random
things with the power e can be pulled
off at the end but there are many ways
of encrypting the same message by just
having different random values here so
that that can do it and elgamal has the
same property here for multiplicative
you have a random value that's part of
this it's just RSA that's completely
deterministic keep all the random values
that were used um you can keep all the
values another way remember when I said
decryption is cumbersome it would be a
matter of figuring out what the random
value what the aggregate random value
would be you can if you do that then
decryption is easy but if you don't keep
that then it's more work to figure out
what the aggregate R would be but but
you can find out um with this there's
actually an easy way to strip away this
R to the N if you know the factorization
of then um regardless you don't have to
keep track of what are generated it okay
forward
there we go okay
so next thing I want to talk about is a
very valuable tool called secret sharing
um has lots of applications and it comes
out of a basic mathematical fact that if
you take any K points in the plane as
long as they have distinct X values then
you can interpolate a polinomial through
them
of degree at most K minus
one okay so why do we care about this
well I'm going to show you the simplest
case the easiest to remember two points
describe a line right if you have two
points you can figure out the line that
goes between them so what I'm going to
do is start off with um points in a
plane and I'm going to take a secret and
my secret value is going to be over here
my secret value is going to be zero in
the exposition and some y value and I'm
not going to tell you what this yvalue
is that's my secret and now I'm going to
draw a random line that goes through
there and I'm going to give everybody in
the room or everybody I want to share
this with points along this
line okay now if later on any two people
come
together they can figure out what the
line is they can figure out where it
hits the Y AIS they find that
point but if there's just one
person then that point could be anywhere
right you don't know could be anything
you could draw a line through those two
points no matter where on the y- axis
the secret is so they're all completely
consistent you literally have zero
information at all even though you've
got in some sense half of what you need
you've got one one of two shares but
you've really got nothing okay so this
generalizes Beyond lines to
arbitrary pols so let's say this this
looks vaguely like a degree four polom
maybe um so maybe I gave out points on
this degree four polinomial so any five
of these points is enough to figure out
what the whole polinomial is and
therefore figure out what the secret is
but if you have only four of these
points then you really have nothing
because any four of these points is
consistent with any possible value here
as a fifth point to give you a degree
for
polinomial so there's a very sharp
threshold in one of these things going
from zero information to complete
information okay once you have this way
of sharing information such that you can
you know build this sharp threshold you
can build a lot of tools out of it um so
the simple way to work with this is just
you know generate um random
pols here's your secret
you have n people you want to share with
any K can
reconstruct and you want to make sure
that uh no fewer than K get any
information whatsoever instead of
thinking of it as building the
polinomial and and points on a
polinomial all you have to do is pick
random coefficients make S be your
constant term because p at zero is going
to be
S and then these are random values and
you just give out this at random points
or or even consecutive points P 1
through n is fine very simple to do very
efficient turns out to be also very
efficient to to reconstruct there are
some very simple interpolation methods
and you can do this geometrically over
reals or rationals but this also works
if you're doing all the computation mod
P so now we get back into the computer
science domain where picking a random
rational number is not an easy thing to
do but picking a random or a set of
random values here in the range zero to
P or 0 to P minus
one that that we know how to do all
those possibilities now are equally
likely and all the possible secrets in
the range Z to P minus one are equally
likely until you reach the threshold of
information okay so this works for
Distributing a secret you can actually
do some interesting computations on
shares turns out uh maybe I should have
put in a slide for this but um if I give
you shares to secret a and somebody else
gives you shares to secret B you can
take your share to a and share to B and
add them and you've got a share to a
plus
b if you work it out basically pols in
some sense are linear in at least in
that sense as operators they are that
that you get a share of just the sum of
the coefficients and everything works
out just all right wait a minute now the
share of the coefficients that's not
right um but um but the points just add
up everything works out well also if you
multiply the same thing happens you get
a share of the product but the problem
is that now the degree of the polinomial
grows so it takes more shares to
reconstruct the polinomial and get the
secret so it works really well for
addition if you're going to do it for
multiplication you have to be able to
deal with more shares maybe correct and
reshare things and there are some tricks
for that um you using techniques like
this and similar techniques you can
develop threshold encryption threshold
encryption is a way of encrypting such
that you have n shareholders of the key
if any K of them are willing to
cooperate they don't have to actually
give their share their their key up or
their whatever piece of the key and
reconstruct the key they can each
perform some function on the cipher text
and after the last one is performed or
you know after they put together their
pieces of the decryptions then you've
decrypted the cipher text okay this has
the application in elections that we
were talking about before right you
don't want one person to be able to
decrypt all the
votes you normally have a Board of
Elections that adjudicates disputes or
whatnot maybe there are five people on
the board maybe it takes a majority to
resolve things so you do a three out of
five threshold encryption scheme on all
the votes and now any three of the
members can get together and decrypt the
sum but it also takes three of them to
collude to figure out how anybody voted
or maybe you want it to be four out of
five you probably don't want it to be
five out of five because then if
somebody doesn't like the way things are
going refuses to decrypt or loses a key
or whatnot you kind of lose the election
which is not a good property so this
threshold thing allows you to have some
robustness and still have some
protection so no one or two or whatever
threshold you set people can figure out
how people voted okay you also can build
group signature schemes group signatures
are sort of what you might think of when
you are signing something important
maybe a bank um is is signing something
or you know something where there's
there are corporate
requirements um and you
want um this is a a check for
$100,000 so it takes three officers to
to sign off on it of out of the
company's six officers say but you can
do it in such a way that you can check
yes this has been signed by a sufficient
number of people but the person
receiving the signature has no idea
which of the legitimate people so some
three of this group of six did sign it
and that's all I need but I don't know
which three and you can even generalize
this in ways so that it can be um the
president of the bank and one vice
president or three vice presidents on
their own or two vice presidents and
three tellers or whatever it is you can
you know generalize it inform form such
that some people have more power than
others and this but you still all you
get is yes this has met the requirements
to be a valid signature I don't know
exactly which set of people signed it
okay again you can see useful
applications
there all right one other um tool I want
to spend some time talking about you may
have heard of this sort of bizar named
thing called zero knowledge and let me
give you a little bit of a sense for
what it is um but any questions before I
go on to this because it's going to take
a few minutes okay so zero knowledge
really comes out to believing something
without seeing it you know seeing is
believing well let's do do it the other
way and if we were in a small group if
there were i' I've done this you know if
there half dozen people I'll do this
with actual cards but I have to simulate
this here so it will be a little less
convincing but you'll get the idea what
I want to claim is that all of these
cards that you imagine I've dealt out
are
red okay and what I think I could do is
show them to you see they're all red but
no I want to convince you
that um they they are red or at least
that a card is Red without you're seeing
it so what I'll let do is deal out these
cards and have you pick a card now if
PowerPoint were really nice and dynamic
I could you know you pick a card and I
flip that card but I have to simulate
this so you just picked card
two right and I turned it over and show
it uh a king and particularly a red King
and then you pick card let's say
five and I turn that over and you pick
card three and I turn that over and you
pick card one and I turn that over and I
remember the sequence right I've done
this before where I've gotten it wrong
and it's embarrassing
okay um so what do you have at this
point um when when you get through this
I've answer all of your challenges
correctly I've shown you that these
cards really are all red so this last
card now you've never seen this card or
the underside of this card but still you
have pretty good reason to believe that
it's red you're not a 100% sure but this
cutand choose thing kind of worked and
you're pretty convinced that it's red in
particular this is a an interesting kind
of belief because it's
non-transferable if if somebody else
walks into the room and say yeah I'm
sure that card is red that person W just
walked in and said okay convince me that
it's red
well I can't I know that it's red or I
have reason to believe it's red but I
have no way of convincing you that it's
red is the essence of why I believe it
and the next person doesn't believe it
the fact that I had the choice of which
ones to sample yes you participated in
this proof so if there's somebody who
was there the whole time but thinks you
might be colluding with me say then they
have no reason to believe it either but
you know either way if you are isolated
from others at the time um and it's your
you're making the choices then you can't
transfer this um if if you're there is
sort of a wire somebody is Whispering to
you choices to make then that person
will be convinced then maybe you
won't is there a way that we can share
some secret uh there there is it becomes
cumbersome there there are a few things
um there's um actually a a more General
approach to this of using the
choices themselves to generate the
randomness um it's called the FIA and
I'm not going to say anything more about
it unless you're interested but it's
it's a really clever way of of handling
this and making a one of these zero
knowledge proofs non-interactive so that
anybody could just look at the proof
after and be convinced of it but is the
nontransferability a feuture or a
antifeature it is usually a feature
sometimes it's an antifeature think of
it in the election context it's a
feature of you're being convinced that
this is your vote without your being
able to show it to somebody else even if
you want to but there are contexts where
it's not not a feature so let me you
know show you what this looks like of
course in the crypto conf um the the
scenario in that context there are no
cards there are encryptions but it's
basically the same thing I show you a
bunch of encryptions I claim these are
all encryptions of the string red and
you pick one let's shortcut it you pick
the one to stay I'll reveal the others
now the way to open these other things
um I'm decommitting in some way so one
thing I could do is if these are
encrypted I show you the randomness that
was used so that you could check
yourself if this is a public e
encryption you can repeat it there are
other ways of opening up commitments you
think of one-way hash functions if I
hash the string red together with a
random
value then if I give you the random
value you can check and say oh yeah that
is Hash of red and a random value not
hash of black and a random value but
until I give you that that key that
random value it's it's committed but
closed so there are lots of ways of
opening this let's just think of this in
the encryption context where this is a
randomized encryption I give you the
bits of Randomness and I open these
other values and show you these were all
red so again you have good reason to
believe this is R now in this case this
is a small case how good your reason is
your your confidence is Is Not Great
there's a one five chance that I could
have duped you in this case so let's
look at a somewhat bigger case maybe I
could have a hundred of these um and
what I say is okay here's an interactive
process I claim that these are all red
or encryptions of red or whatever and
you pick one and identify that and then
I open up all the others and so you all
the others are red and you think okay
that one is probably red too and now
since you would have had to or if if I'm
proving to you I would have had to guess
in advance which of these hundred that
you would pick in order to cheat you my
chance of getting away with a black card
under there is really just one in a 100
right if I really want to cheat you then
um the I have to guess your random pick
in advance and I've got a one in a 100
chance of doing that which is better but
it's still this goes up only linearly
and we'd like to do a lot better than
this in getting high confidence these
are weak interactive proofs let me
question or
yeah you begin with the title zero
knowledge yeah what is the thing that is
what's I I don't have knowledge of the
remaining card yes but now I have
knowledge of the other 99 right where
are you hiding something well so the the
idea is that these other 99 are
uninteresting in some way they might be
ritten so how did you manage to put the
only interesting data behind the card
that I happened to pick well it might be
I need 100 shares to find the
interesting no let me it'll become clear
later on but let me just give sort of a
preview suppose I want to generate um I
want to produce an RSA key with some
properties and if you factor it you can
see that oh yeah this is
the two primes had certain properties
now I generate 100 things with these
properties 99 of them are going to be
thrown away the H hundredth you believe
also has these properties but that 100th
is still protected okay so that's that's
one approach this but I still want to do
better than this one in 100 um what I
want to do is instead of this where you
challenge Me by picking one value and
I've got a one and 100 chance of
guessing the value in in advance and
hiding the right thing thing under there
I'm going to say what you're going to do
is pick a subset of these 100
things and I want to make it so that the
only way that I can get away with
cheating is if I could predict your
exact
subset now there's a one and two chance
on this one and a one and two chance on
this one and a one and two chance on
this one of my guessing correctly there
are 100 things here the chance of
my guessing correctly which subset you
pick is one and two the
100 right roughly 10 to the 30th okay
this is not going to happen this is like
you picked a key and encrypted something
I just guessed you're
kid could happen in
theory hopefully doesn't happen in
practice
otherwise uh I'm not doing my job
right okay so if we can do this this is
much much stronger and there are ways
and let me give you a little bit of
intuition before I show you you know
what what this would actually look like
so the way to think of this is doing
what's called a zero knowledge proof of
knowledge and suppose what I want to do
is prove to you that I can get from some
starting point might be a graph might be
you know um some sort of a a map or some
complicated structure a maze of some
sort I can get from the start to the
Finish I know a way of getting there but
I don't want to show you the way of
getting there that's the0 knowledge
part I I'm protective of this this is
valuable what I can do this is mostly
just intuition is pick 100 intermediate
points somewhere in this long large
complicated graph or or structure and
wait for you to challenge so you'll
challenge by picking a random subset of
these things and say you identify those
and for anything that you identify I'll
show you that I know how to get from the
start
to there and everything else that you
didn't pick I'll show you that I know
how to get from these intermediate
points to the
Finish now if there's any single case
any single example where I can get both
from the start to a point and from that
point to the
Finish then I can get
there but giving you this information I
haven't shown you any path from the
start to the
Finish suppose I want to cheat
you well well
since in every case you um challenged me
I gave you the correct response I showed
you that I could give you the the path
that I was supposed to then if I were in
even one case able to answer the
opposite way then you know that I can
get from the start to the finish so the
only way I could possibly have cheated
you and not be able to get from the
start to the Finish is if I know exactly
in advance what choices you're going to
make and then I can structure things so
yeah here's something I know how to get
to the Finish from here's something I
know how to get to from the start or I
think I did this backwards but anyway I
can get to this from the start so I'll
create a point here that I can get to
from the start I'll create a point here
that I can get to the finish on Etc and
give these points I still don't know how
to get to from start to the Finish but I
can convince you that I do if I guess in
advance exactly what set you're going to
pick yeah to convince me that you look
from start to the Finish you have to
know not only how to get from the start
to the Finish but how to get from the
start every point in the set oh I pick
these points these are intermediate
points that I picked okay um so this is
intuition right now I'll I'll give you a
a more structured form of this in a
minute but let me start off with a more
direct problem that you might run into
um I claimed to have a private key
corresponding to a known public key so
there may be a certificate of some sort
that been issued in my name you and the
person with the certificate and with
this private key is supposed to have
access to some resources this is a very
common thing I should be able to get
into this bank account I should be able
to you know um order some some
merchandise or order some action be
taken or or have access to some data or
whatever okay um so here's here's my
certificate this is showing that I
should be able to get there if I have
the corresponding private K how do I
show you that I have the corresponding
private key well one way is I can give
you the corresponding private key I say
okay well yeah I guess so all right good
you check it you know you check that
matches the the public key it works
great you let me in not so good next
time because now you have the private
gate doesn't work so well so here's a
somewhat better method
maybe I prove to you my ability to
decrypt a message of your
choice that shows you that I really do
presumably have the private key because
you encrypted with the public key I can
decrypt you believe it okay except now
I'm being an oracle maybe you've got
this message that you really want to
decrypt you've been trying you're you're
the NSA maybe or who whoever you've been
wanting to decrypt this for a long time
and and here I come along saying okay
I'll decrypt one thing for you
great okay that's not good and and you
can hide this in various ways so that
it's not obvious to me that I'm
decrypting something that might be of
value to you so I don't want to just
decrypt some message of your choice what
I want to do is something a little bit
more sophisticated I want to decrypt the
message of your choice but only after
I'm sure that you already know the
decryption so it's zero knowledge for
you you will not learn anything from my
decrypting this
okay how can I do this well let's go
back to this uh sort of graph case I
start off with this encrypted value that
you gave to me you showed me this value
you wanted me to decrypt it for you what
what will happen
is um you will also create 100 more
dummy encryptions of things that you
don't care about and that I presumably
don't care about doesn't matter these
are all your encryptions of of other
things and I
will challenge you I'll pick a random
subset of your dummies your dummy
encryptions grab those and say okay
prove to me that you really did have
decryptions of these and you open them
and say okay I believe it on those what
about the rest what I'll say is for each
of the rest you should show me that you
know M times the decryption of this
thing so here's this encrypted message
here's this if you have both M * M2 and
M2 then you have M and you've convinced
me that you're able to get the
decryptions of anything that I asked you
to decrypt so if you had the decryption
of this and you had this then you do
already have
M okay those two things together
give me that
confidence of your you must already have
the encryption of you must already have
M itself so now I'm willing to give you
m because you presumably already know it
and in fact if this is a homomorphic
encryption function we could save a step
and do this the other way around what it
could happen is I you give me encryption
of M I give you a bunch of these
dummies and I'll decrypt for you
you without ever opening M I'll just
prove to you that I know the encryption
the decryption of of this I prove to you
you give me he have am I prove to you
that I know m without ever giving you m
by um I give you a bunch of these
dummies you challenge me and I'll open
things according to your challenges and
you can check that these are correct
because um e of this has a valid
encryption of e of M time e of M2 which
you can generate on your own if it's
homomorphic so you can save a step there
but you know only a quick step but this
gets at the idea okay there are other
kinds of zero knowledge proofs also you
know very powerful can do a lot of
things very high confidence that certain
things are true okay yeah question we
use a signature to prove ownership of
the V key um well again then I would be
signing something
where did it come from if I'm signing my
own something that I chose to sign then
you might say well maybe I got this from
somebody else who really has the key and
I just got that person to sign something
last week if I'm signing something of
your choice then I'm signing something
that you've just given me and I don't
know maybe it's a contract the pledge to
give you a million dollars so you've got
that same thing of before I signed it I
want to know that it's okay in some
sense and you want to be sure that it's
not some old thing you want it to be
fresh so you want to give it to me but I
don't want to just sign something that
you gave to me so you have exactly the
same thing coming up in that case so I
telling to understand the distinction
between zero knowledge and zero
knowledge proof of knowledge why isn't
this called zero knowledge why is it
called zero knowledge proof of knowledge
well in this case what I'm just proving
um in this little piece what I'm proving
is I'm I know the decryption of this
value without actually revealing this
value okay okay um it's one kind of zero
knowledge proof there are zero knowledge
proofs that don't have this structure at
all um I can show you that I can
distinguish between things of a certain
kind without giving you too much
information and prove to you that um
certain graph problems are solvable
graph isomorphism or graph
non-isomorphism or classic cases be
called zero knowledge proof of
distinguishability uh some some of them
are zero knowledge proof of
distinguishability in general it's all
just zero knowledge proofs this is just
one class of zero knowledge proofs okay
so I've left just enough time to get
back to the election example because I
really want to do this
okay the
threshold
homomorphism was able to get at the
problem of who can decrypt these zero
knowledge proof proofs can get at the
other problems that that I mentioned um
you can use them so that I as a voter
can go up to a device and it can encrypt
on my behalf and I can be sure that it's
encrypting the right thing I can be sure
that it's encrypted red or whatever
party that is or whatever candidate that
is without it revealing to me the
details that will allow me to go to
another person and show that this other
person how I voted also you can use the
zero knowledge process to show everybody
that this really is an encryption of red
or black or zero or one and not an
encryption of a million um uh and get
make make sure that it's a legitimate
election so let let me give you the the
detailed application I've been working
on um two sessions ago
um May 2nd I guess it was not not the
last one I ran out of this room and went
directly to the
airport um went down to Travis County
Texas where we're working on an election
project now Travis County Texas is one
of I think 249 counties in
Texas um seems like you a small thing
except if you look inside Travis
County um that's Austin there are a
million people there it's not quite that
small um there's a project that we're
working on very interesting requirements
I won't go into all the details of why
we're doing it this way but we're
building one of these cryptographically
verifiable election systems for for
Austin and other counties are starting
to get really interested for reasons
I'll get into it in a minute so let me
show you what the process looks like
what we've designed is a voter will go
in sign in to
vote get some sort of a
token and go up to a ballot marking
device basically
a
tablet in fact probably a win8
tablet
um uh with nice TPM and nice all sorts
of nice features but there are a lot of
reasons why WI a tablets work really
well here but basically use this device
to make selections nice full featured
device you can make make your choices
check them change them um if people who
have accessibility needs can go use
headphones just plug them into a USB
port whatever there are all sorts of
things um that that are really nice and
easy to do here this isn't voting this
is marking a ballot so what happens when
you're finished with this and you say
okay I'm happy I want to vote is you get
a
receipt this receipt has three
parts it has actually in clear text
what's sometimes called a ballot summary
this is a list of of the choices that
you've made it's not the full ballot of
all the possible choices it's just these
are the selections I made so it's it's
quite
compact you get the encryption because
the whole point was that we have an
encrypted ballot so here it is and a 2d
barcode and you get some sort of a
take-home receipt you could take home
the entire encryption but really
anybody's going to want to deal with is
just probably a hash of the encryption
just something short a hash code of some
sort one-way hash
okay what a voter can do is take this
receipt remove the take-home part
perforated this could also come as two
separate pieces of paper one is the
ballot summary and encryption one is
your take-home
receipt take that off and with this
thing haven't voted yet you have one of
two
choices
either you cast that Ballot or you spoil
that ballot casting that ballot means go
over drop it into a Ballot Box okay part
of the system is um every polling site
has a Ballot Box um the voter actually
cast the vote by dropping that piece of
paper in The Ballot Box it doesn't count
if it didn't make it into The Ballot Box
we now have a paper record if anybody
wants to check the paper here it is it's
in The Ballot Box scanner in the box
actually reads the ballot number so we
know yes that ballot in the Box
electronically the the ballot captured
by the ballot marking device that
encryption can go back over the the
local network to the host machine and be
preserved it's not cast if it doesn't
make into The Ballot Box what's the
other choice spoil which is go back to
the pole worker and say I'm not happy I
looked at this this ballot summary I
don't I've changed my mind I want to
vote differently or for whatever reason
I'm not happy a spoiled ballot acts as a
challenge in one of these interactive
proofs in a sort of subtle way that
doesn't have to be in voters faces but
anybody who actively wants to gain
confidence that this is an appropriate
encryption can spoil a ballot or two
okay a spoiled ballot means a voter
takes this ballot to the poll work ER
gets a new voting token can retain the
receipt and even copy of the spoiled
ballot if desired and go home after
repeating the process as many times as
desired anything else has not been voted
okay so what do we have at the end of
this
process here's the verifiable record
that comes out here we've got all the
cast ballots in encrypted form they
posted publicly on a public
website we've got all the spoiled
ballots and their decryptions together
with any Keys any Randomness necessary
to decrypt
them so you as a voter what are you
likely to do with your receipt probably
crumble it up and throw it
away that's okay it's okay if 99% of
Voters do
that some small fraction of
voters might check go on the website
take a look at the receipt make sure oh
yeah my ballots up there if you're
really diligent and you spoiled the vote
oh yeah my spoiled vote is up there and
it decrypted the way I was expecting it
to that's the check that's sort of this
cut and shoes this yes it's red it
opened to the color I was expecting to
the vote I was
expecting you're probably only doing it
once or twice at most but there are a
lot of Voters out there this list
doesn't have to be very long to gain
pretty high
confidence how do you know that the
spoiled ballot is
correct you
have um if I bought my receipt home I
would know that what I thought should
have been on there is on there yes but
everybody else's spoiled ballot yeah I
have no way of knowing if it's correct
you're responsible for checking your own
bot to some extent part of the record is
this and what will be checked by any
election verifier out there is this
Association and I'll get to this a
little bit more in a minute and that all
of these decryptions are correct so you
don't have to check that this decryption
matches you just you you check that this
is what you're expecting and sort of
it's part of the election record that
this is consistent with that according
to this K so you you could imagine that
election verifiers are written by the
candidates probably the candidates
parties maybe election meeting media um
sorry um um the the uh broadcast media
um uh special interest groups League of
Women Voters ACLU whatever anybody who's
interested and it's not that hard um a
uh professor at Rice who who was part of
this project assigned to his first year
programming T class a task of writing
election verifiers for this kind of a
system twoe project most first year
programming students were able to do
this so not that bad and you can sort of
download as many election verifiers as
you want run as many as you want or what
most voters will do is believe the
results that's okay you have your choice
you can choose who to trust here so just
quickly how is the this process work
well what we have is encrypted ballots
you see you can't see what's in there
they're
encrypted okay let's take a look this
might be what what they encryptions of
um let's make a little
room if we take these encryptions and
multiply them together we have an
additively homomorphic function so that
product matches the sum and we get
exactly what we should get there now
that's not what's actually seen what's
seen is this these are encrypted but at
the end of the process the requisite
number the threshold number of election
officials can come along and decrypt
this aggregate value provide the
randomness so that you can check anybody
can check that this really is a correct
decryption of this aggregate value that
matches all of these things provide all
this and you've got a verified
election okay yep but I haven't verified
that those casted ballot correspond to
actual voters you not somebody some
malicious a good point so um the way
that I prefer doing this is there's also
a name next to each of these this is my
ballot I can check this and then anybody
can check and say oh wait a minute that
person died last year or moved away or
whatnot it's preferred that this be done
with actual names um there are many
reasons why people are squeamish about
doing it that way um so what we are
actually doing in practice in this case
is these things are associated with the
the take-home receipts and there are
other more traditional checks that the
right number of ballots are in place
everybody has signed in that's what that
first step was you can get a count of
the people who have signed in you can
check this against the count of you know
posted ballots everybody has the ability
to to actually check that their posted
ballot is there now in King County when
you mail in a ballot we have the the
process where you can check online and
say oh y my ballot has been received
it's been counted according to the
election office it's a a claim that
they've made there's no real confidence
that you have here you can check and say
yep there is my ballot it's there it is
actually part of the count and you get
that confidence yeah kind of similar is
there a way for me as a voter to um
prove to the verifier that um my ballot
should have been cast like I put it in
The Ballot
Box um not explicitly this the way to
think of this is as an audit mechanism
you can tell if something's gone wrong
you can't necessarily correct it if it's
gone wrong um you can shout and complain
and wait a minute yeah I've got this
receipt you know look at this it's a
legitimate receipt where is my ballot if
you're the only one doing that then you
know people might say well maybe it's a
forgery of some sort you know do some
forensic analysis on it maybe not
whatever if thousands of people are
saying this they've got this paper
record something really seems to be
wrong this is going to require
investigation but at least you know in
current systems you've got no idea put
the ballot in the Box go home close your
eyes here's the count see you in four
years you know that's as much as as you
can verify here at least you can see
when something's gone wrong okay yeah is
it possible to make each vote more
secure than the aggregate sum or does
that require trusting a l conclusion um
secure in what sense private less decry
um with this system no with this system
um no and it's hard to imagine a way
that it could be because imagine that
what I do is the trustees come together
but they've just removed this last vote
from the pro from the process and they
decrypt without that last vote then they
decrypted an aggregate but by doing that
and decrypting with that vote in and
without that vote in they know what that
last vote is so in some sense that's you
know as decryptable as the T if you can
decrypt aggregate
T it it seems like if you signed um the
ballot um as I put it in The Ballot Box
then I have a way to prove to you the
you know custody of of my ballot
potentially it turns out signatures
don't help a lot here because any
malicious device is going to give you a
bad
signature so now if you go home with
this and you come back and say I was
cheated they'll say well that signature
is not right so you have to have a way
of checking that signature in real time
to make that that a useful mitigation
okay please yep so the focus here seems
to be uh to protect against fraud uh uh
to protect against to ensure that the
tally is correct right okay uh and and
that the voter can verify that his vote
was accounted for correctly and that all
recorded votes were properly talled
right so is there a way to so in a
different country in a different place
you would might also need to be
protected against coercion yes oh that
that's very important here if we don't
want to protect against coercion then
it's really easy we just open this up
and publish the list with the names this
is all designed so that you have
protection against coercion because
you're casting your vote in in this
particular scenario it's in a in a
monitored poll site people are ensuring
that there's nobody over your shoulder
while you're having this device cast
create a ballot on your behalf create an
encrypted ballot and you can't decrypt
that ballot so you can't show it to a
third party you got this
non-transferable zero knowledge proof
effectively um so if once I get the the
uh so for that to happen I should leave
the my token behind is that right or
because if I take the the the token out
of the voting uh the pulling boot then
the token isn't the randomness the the
token that I showed you at the very
beginning of the process sorry I meant
this receipt no the the receipt is just
a receipt of the encrypted value the
receipt doesn't allow it to be
decrypted TT oh the plain text that
stays in that plain there are the two
things that you receive the ballot
summary the plain text that goes in The
Ballot Box if that didn't make into The
Ballot Box it's not a vote so if you
took it home that's not how you voted
because you didn't
vote so you you you have that
there another yeah yeah so given that
there's so much sort of structure here
it also seems easy to like if I put if I
somehow squeezing some noise into that
thing I invalidate everything in some
sense right I mean it's um if if you
manage to get you know one ballot with a
million here if I have a bit there like
something happens then then everybody
throws up the in saying oh I don't know
what happened something is wrong yeah so
um it shouldn't have happen there's a
lot here to try to keep that from
happening um there you know there should
be a an interactive proof that every one
of these ballots is legitimate so you
know one and two to the 100 chance that
illegitimate ballot gets through but
there are other mechanisms we've built
in a post-election audit mechanism and
we've got that paper trail if anybody
ever cares there's still that box of
actual ballots there that people can can
go through okay uh I maybe as part that
so I mean I I could go home and just
take a barcode printer and print some
random noise and it may not decrypt what
I want but it might not go well in that
process so is there also a signing
component or something like that uh how
would The Ballot Box know that it's fake
right um so The Ballot Box is on a local
network here so what's happening is The
Ballot Box is com communicating with the
ballot marking device and it's that that
okay here's a ballot ID that's active
right now you know let me know you know
you should probably see it within the
next few minutes let me know when you do
and I'll you know record that that
ballot as now being a cast ballot um so
so that's that's where the process is
it's all done locally this is not
internet connected this is a local
network so is that where the token the
token is just
um the the the lingo here is a ballot
style you can walk into a polling site
that might have thousands of different
local races for different jurisdictions
and the token is just which local races
are you eligible to vote for the way
they do it in in Travis County is you
can go into any poll site anywhere in
the county from anywhere and there may
be different ballots available so that's
what that's for yeah so I want to know
what sort of key material is needed uh
not to decrypt but to encrypt this
public it's all public key material so
the public keys of the trustees
effectively so nothing
sensitive yep yeah to follow the
intention of evidence here um so with
cast ballots you are not you're showing
the the the encryption encrypted form
but not the actual votes the trustees
have the capabil of decrypting it they
could post a decrypted list if they
wanted to We Trust the trustees what is
the motivation for not just posting the
the the individual mappings between cast
ballot and list and individual votes if
the C the voter's name is not out there
um that can be done there is a a
coercion threat called pattern voting
the idea is that I want you to vote for
me as mayor and there are these little
judgeship races and County uh um dog
catcher races at the bottom of the
ballot and I want you to vote for this
judge this judge this judge this in this
particular pattern and there are so many
little races out there that I can assign
you one pattern and everybody else a
distinct pattern and then I say your
vote had better show up with this
pattern had better show up for me as
mayor or you're going to lose your job
and that's the thing protect casting
separate ballots for each race yeah
effectively what happens is they they
get split up per race and we do actually
post the decrypted for post elction
audit purposes we post a list of the the
individual votes that are cast but um
they are the the the ballots that they
are associated with are shrouded they
are um encrypted or or hashed um
committed to and for post-election
auditing processes we can go and pick
random votes and say you know here's
this list that says there were you know
32,000 votes for this candidate let's
pick this one and find the paper ballot
that's supposed to be associated with it
and we can do that but we don't want to
have that list associated with the
actual ballot numbers open because then
you
can piece together the ballots and do
this pattern voting
check okay is there a mailing solution
all
have to physically go there to vote um
this is designed as an in-person system
there are mailin ways of doing similar
things um right now what we're doing
here is um any any remote ballot just
gets remade and added to the system you
don't have an opportunity to as an
individual voter to check that your
ballot if it's remote has been entered
properly eventually we want to do that
but first pass that's not part of the
system so two more
slides so why do we do this well current
technology um we have to trust things
with current election systems you have
to trust the people that manage the
election you have no choice if if
they're corrupt you know you might know
they're corrupt hey you it's the mayor
give me your vote yeah um yeah right um
the equipment and its manufacturers you
have to
trust um and that's a big Pro growing
problem because often the officials just
sort of bring in the equipment people
and say uh we don't know what's going on
you tell us what happened um and the the
process is used with this method what
I'm showing you here is you can
eliminate this trust you don't have to
trust anybody or if you don't really
understand the crypto or don't want to
do the check yourself you still have the
benefit because you get to choose who to
trust you choose your candidate or your
party or your favorite news media or or
whoever else rather than these are the
people you have to trust and if you
don't like it go take a walk okay yeah
don't you still need to trust the
officials since they hold the decryption
Keys um you trust privacy in the
collective um uh uh Trustees of the
election so if the trustees of the
election all collude they could Reveal
Your vote in fact if the ballot marking
device is corrupt it could Reveal Your
vote because it could retain the r
Randomness that it used in generating
the encryption and then Supply it to a
third party um so there is trust for
privacy but the Integrity of the
election the actual the tally is being
correct is is absolute you don't have to
trust anybody is there any tying between
the user's identity and everything that
goes from the ballot marking device on
in this system no once you vote um then
you know your your ballot ID is is is
retained but your identity is not but
you do go home with a receipt that you
know somebody could say okay give me the
receipt I I also have all the decryption
keys I'll check all this yeah sorry you
answer this question
again how am I sure that all of all of
the votes
legitimate um the U you mean 01
legitimate or from legitimate people all
the votes that show up I know that one
matches and it's all good but how am I
sure that all the other ones correspond
to legitimate votes well so so there are
there are two kinds of legitimate here
there's is this does this vote match my
intentions my My Chosen selections and
that's up to each voter to to check but
is this vote from a legitimate voter yes
is another
question my preferred way of doing that
is we do have a list of names um next to
every vote and then it's a matter of
public record you can just sort of check
and look and see are are you know check
your neighborhood you know there are
people who do canvasing regularly and
and check to the voter roles and close
elections and and and who's actually
voted um but um in lie of that right now
with this system where we we don't have
names posted it's more traditional
processes of there's a list of people
who have signed in here are the people
who voted here are the actual votes the
numbers match and we we get it that way
yeah just want to check trust so the the
election trustees have the private key
is required to decou the final home Mor
tally yes they're going to keep that
secret um how do we verify that the
result of the home tally decrypts to the
actual results um it's a it's a
verifiable decryption what's actually
released is not just the decryption but
the randomness the the random component
so that anybody can take the public
encryption function the the encrytion
and the random value and encrypt and say
yep here's the encryption if I take
these two things encrypt I get that so
this is a correct
decryption okay last slide apologies for
running over seems to be a lot of I
really this is good good good thing I
appreciate the interest another benefit
of this is cost and this is where a lot
of the county Travis County wants to do
this because of good election Integrity
they really seem to care about doing
things right there are a bunch of other
big counties in Texas that have suddenly
gotten interested in this and B
basically because what they're doing is
this traditional method which is they've
got this proprietary equipment that's
gone through elaborate certification
processes and it's not clear that
certification has much value but there's
been all this certification it's
expensive to certify it's expensive to
purchase because this is proprietary
stuff expensive to maintain we're
changing the model here you're not
certifying the election equipment
anymore and then closing your eyes and
hoping that you know it's still good
we're certifying actual elections
doesn't matter what the equipment is so
we can use cots we can use off-the-shelf
you know tablets much cheaper a lot of
these other counties are saying hey yeah
cheaper that's good um and you know they
this wasn't my intention getting
involved in this but as I mentioned
earlier when the analysis was done by
people at Rice on on what the best
voting terminal was they came out with
by far WI a tablets are the best thing
for this so hey great I'm happy about
that anyway big butons big buttons um
well large display um long battery life
peripherals being able to lots of USB
ports TPM is a nice thing to have so you
you can have confidence that the right
cat is running for privacy reasons for
for other things there there are a lot
of benefits to having a a WIA tablet and
also they're cheaper than
than some of the Alternatives so it
seems like a very good choice now you
know we're not going to make or break
the company on on this but yeah hey it's
it's a bonus okay I've gotten to the end
any final
questions yes have a final question this
is not s this is not but you have a lot
of experience with voting so the
previous Slide the one where you
actually said today we have to trust the
officials and cryptography allows us to
overcome your audience are people
who the you know science is like they
don't trust in science so that's the
audience absolutely right so it's just
feels like fighting a losing battle so
many people who said well yeah you don't
have to trust election officials but
you're asking me to trust cryptography
instead that's
worse and you know or even mathematics
or you know something like that it's um
my answer to that is um at least with
this model you can choose who to trust
you're not forced to trust these people
you don't have to learn the mathematics
but you can trust if you like Fox News
you can trust Fox News
whoever I missed that I said that only
works if Fox News has a mathematician I
mean the point if your particular you
know Community says well this is you
know a bunch of focus Pocus so so an
election verifier but Fox News already
does that
yeah it's true the the a a legitimate
election verifier app has two outputs
two possible outputs one is yes this
verifies but the other is not no this
doesn't verify the other is no this
doesn't verify because this step here is
supposed to be a plus b and it's not and
and anybody should be able to check you
know wait a minute here's here's the
point you can't get away with saying no
I tried it it didn't verify so I don't
believe it that you know you should
shouldn't buy yeah so I think you
already answered this I just want to
make sure so did you say that uh anybody
can take the all the words published and
run through the the home or encryption
and decrypt it decrypt the results and
say this tally is correct not anybody
can do it only the election trustees can
can collectively decrypt the aggregate
tally and then prove that it's correct
in a way that any body else can
verify how do they prove it by releasing
the the associated Randomness so think
of I should have spent more time on this
I apologize but what you can do is think
of a public encryption as encrypting two
values the data and a random component
and those two together encrypt to form
the cipher text up here now if I take
this and decrypt it I could just give
you the the data but you have no idea of
that whether it's correct or not but if
I also give you the randomness then you
can check yourself by re-encrypting and
saying ah the the randomness together
with the the data that does correspond
to that so so that way the the the
officials don't have to reveal their
private key absolutely not they should
not ever do that yeah okay yes what do
you think about like voting schemes like
Estonia where they have everyone has
their own um certificate um Estonia is
broken um yeah Estonia has been very
proud of their you know internet voting
system for a few years um they got a
little too loud about claiming it's
great and a couple of of friends and
colleagues went over and if you look at
the news just the last month they went
over and showed how easy it was to break
the Estonian election system and just
before the European elections and um so
that it's completely vulnerable you can
create any T you want it's not not that
hard even and you know there there were
people in Estonia who really knew this
there were people who understood this
and tried to get them to do it right and
failed so now this is very public and of
course there's a lot of embarrassment
and there's a lot of distrust of these
you know people who have come in and and
broken their system but um it's it's
getting some attention um so you there
have been people who have tried internet
voting and and people there have been
countries that have tried internet
voting um for the most part they're not
doing a good job and there are some
states that are starting to do some
internet voting uh we do know how to do
it well it's not being done
well yes so what do you see any flaws in
the system do you see any
weaknesses um I see a lot of benefits in
this system as is there are still some
issues the the biggest thing that I
would like to to have that's not here
and what I showed you is if I see
corruption or I corruption isn't the
right term but I I see that I've been
cheated my ballot has not been
posted um or I see that it's posted I I
tried to vote for Adams I spoiled it and
what got posted was a spoiled vote for
Jefferson so there I was doing the
interactive proof you claimed all red
and I challenged you and turned over a
card and it came out
black okay now I know there's Mal going
on I know cheating I don't have any way
to prove that to a third
party because that's indistinguishable
in this system from I really did ask for
a vote for black um and it gave me a
vote for black how I in the Privacy so
having evidence of Malin would be a
useful thing to add you spoil your you
keep the label thing you keep the label
thing but only you know who it was that
you voted for so oh you you mean the
sorry the the ballot summary yeah you
got a sheet of paper that came out of
the marking machine right right and it's
got the name of it's got you know jeffon
on it yeah it it it does there's a
question of Master of data there what's
the master of data the encrypted data or
the printed yeah text it it could be
that the encryption is actually an
encryption of Adams Even though it
Prince Jefferson oh no right but so so
so the point is if you if you go and you
look in the on the on the website and
the and the decryption of the of the
barcode was was Adams but it says
Jefferson on the sheet of paper now you
can go to the election officials and say
hey why don't you guys decrypt this
ballot and you'll see it doesn't match
up um I think you know You' got a good
point that I hadn't realized but I think
where you have to do is you have to go
to the piece of find the piece of paper
in The Ballot Box because but it's not
in the Box because this was a spell
ballot right so I got to take it oh
right right you're right right no but
can you actually make a copy of a spell
ballot and change the name ballot still
has its play text on it you can prove
that it doesn't match uh yeah it does
you're right if if you can
if if if there's good Providence of that
that piece of paper and forensically
this is legitimately printed yeah yeah
that's I hadn't realized that thank you
very very useful for me okay good and
this does this stop does this what the
Google Glasses attack uh no so there are
still you know um this is something I've
been concerned about a lot lately CRA
Craig knows that basically you know the
we we've done all this work um for a
century and a half on this notion of
What's called the Australian ballot
which is this very sophisticated process
that we just take for granted don't even
realize what's going on but the process
is we vote privately in a publicly
monitored environment and that's
supposed to thwart coercion and it
worked for 150 years it was invented in
the 1850s it worked pretty well that
there are people there to watch that
you're not being coerced when you fill
out your ballot and you close up your
ballot and you drop it in The Ballot Box
that doesn't work when people are
wearing cameras
everywhere and it turns out there are
some really serious attacks with you
know um glasses with cameras in the
bridge of the nose and you know all
sorts of things and we've got a you know
there are some ways in which we might be
able to deal with them but it gets makes
things much harder but
that's a whole other area that I'd love
to deal
with Force Co someone having wearning
glasses to prove that they Lear the
correct way uh yeah you you could
certainly you know I'm your employer I I
want the videotape
tomorrow um or you lose your job yeah
and and it's possible to do that very
efficiently too on large scale I I can
just you know I I I have 100 employees I
don't have to review all of them I have
I can review two or three of them you're
you're still going to do it because you
might threat of losing your job so
anyway okay so one one final thing
before we wrap up is um there is a
survey and if you want to uh respond I
know look like the worst thing in the
world is to give a URL that you can't
click on here but if you go to consensus
I think all you need to do is get that
or just remember that and we will I
think try to mail this out to everybody
whose name we have um so we've got that
at least and if you're watching remotely
okay you have time to copy slowly but
just go to consensus and then you can
fill in the rest pretty easily that's
the most important thing if you don't
have access to the survey contact Josh
uh yeah let me know I think we I checked
it there's an everyone box that I
checked so I I think we've got that is
that
secure no this is purely trust
them it is supposedly Anonymous but who
knows anyway thank you very
much